the wild card game the first of
potentially three bueller eight starts
during the regular season 1-0 at 348 era
36 and two-thirds just 14 earned runs 24
hits down on strikes as yelich and we
are underway bueller eight starts during
the regular season 1-0 at 3 48 era braun
swings and misses on a slider dropped by
smith throws to first to complete the
strikeout two up two down in the first
jericho 248 with nine home runs 17 runs
batted in and he launches one to left
field back goes
aj pollock he's there to make the catch
no runs no hits though there's nobody
left here's sprint suiter we don't know
how long he's gonna go we're not
entirely sure who's gonna follow him
either is dave roberts and away we go
drills one to right field braun going
back at the wall he can't get it to flex
off the wall bet's on his way to second
base and he will hold there with a lead
off double in the bottom of the first
bases are loaded
second walk issued by brent sooner in
the opening inning the 3-0 smith takes
outside a four-pitch walk and the
dodgers take a one-to-nothing lead
in game one of the wild card game
suitor's 29th pitch of the first pollock
taking outside
ball four but the dodgers take a two to
nothing lead thanks to four walks given
up by suitor here in the bottom of the
first
round has been great since he joined the
brewers at 3 28.
fastball swung on and missed strike
three that's the third strikeout already
for bueller bueller said at the belt
garcia leads off first and arceus
strikes out swinging basketball at 97.
mookie double the right in the first
inning
and there's a line drive into center
field for a base hit taylor will score
easily and on his way to second base
with a head first sliding double mookie
bets he's two for two with a pair of
doubles and the dodgers take a
three-nothing lead
another one missing arm side ball four
he walked five guys all year he's walked
five guys tonight craig council may have
said that is the last walk that grant
suiter is going to issue tonight 51
pitches eric yardley's come out of the
game and deals again and that one's hit
in the air in a right and deep warning
track and it is going to be
caught by ryan braun lead off batter is
a board for omar narvaez
right down broadway strike three three
straight fastballs from mueller 99
narvaez is done ryan braun on on two
breaking ball swung on and missed strike
three that's gonna end the inning two
strikeouts per inning through the first
three fielder gets ready to work against
jed jerko jerko swings and misses at a
fastball up around the eyes he's down on
strikes bueller seven strikeouts now
walker biller who has had seven or more
in every appearance that he has made in
the postseason first time the brewers
have had a man in scoring position in
the game pitch to arcia
swinging a fly ball left center field
tagged well it is gone
orlando arcia two-run home run on an 0-2
pitch
and he gets the brewers right back into
game one of the wild card series the
stretch by bueller
breaking ball call strike three that'll
end the inning two strikeouts for
bueller in each of the first four in it
3-2 is the score and it's a 3-2 count on
chris taylor 3-2 pitch from yardley
is a called third strike on the outside
corner and the first strikeout for
brewers pitching tonight
and it's a swing and a miss he chased
the sinker down and in
back-to-back strikeouts
for eric yardley in this fourth inning
julio aureus is on the mound you see
what he's done in 11 games a terrific
era 327 and now there's going to be a
pinch hitter jacob nottingham sure looks
like an injury you don't take a guy with
a 337 lifetime average in the postseason
out in the fifth inning against the
left-handed pitcher this was ryan braun
making that catch earlier against the
wall huge loss for the milwaukee brewers
brian braun swinging the back really
well
last few weeks of the season
nottingham swings and misses down on a
94 mile an hour fast one down garcia off
second
fulldom and rcf strikes out curveball
has been a very effective pitch for
urias tonight that's his fourth
strikeout the 3-2
little chopper back to the mound various
throws to first and that's going to do
it no runs one hit one error one left
after five and a half dodgers three
milwaukee
there's two out nobody on and christian
yelled coming up left hander throws a
swing and a line drive down the left
field line of fair ball it's into the
corner as christian yelich with two
strikes goes the other way and delivers
a double dodgers certainly heavily
favored coming into this game in this
series and taylor pops it up left side
of the infield
justin turner's there makes the catch
and that will end the inning now corey
seeger oh for two drew a walk and scored
in the first but 2-2
fly ball center field well hit on his
way it's got a chance and it's gone a
home run corey seeger has given the
dodgers a huge insurance run
it's four to two
jansen's one out away it's a tough out
christian yelich who's hit it hard twice
tonight swung on and missed strike three
and the dodgers hang on and take a one
game to none lead in the best of three
in the wild card series